let's bring in rachel rizzo she's a
political analyst and director
of programs at the truman center she
joins us from washington d.c
tonight good to see you again rachel
well
let me ask you about what president
trump was asked earlier today a reporter
asked him
if he's prepared both a victory speech
and a concession speech
and he answered in an unusually somber
tone do you think he senses that the the
polling numbers
might be right after all
well i think that's a great question
that you ask um but i think that
what's helpful is to point to the fact
that for weeks if not months um trump
has
hinted that he may not concede
even if um polls show that joe biden is
is ahead um so i think that we'll have
to see exactly
exactly what happens there he has also
said that he could declare victory
even if he is not the clear winner but
as we all know
that's not in the constitution so it
really doesn't matter if he comes out
and declares victory
but that could cause a lot of confusion
so that is definitely something we're
concerned about and watching closely
every four years the u.s presidential
election
becomes the world's election if you will
people all over the planet they feel
like
they are a part of this process in some
way
that has it's been a benefit for america
in the past
this time around though it looks like a
liability
would you agree with that
absolutely and it's really concerning to
read reports that have
been coming out from you know human
rights organizations saying that
people need to be watching what happens
with the elections in the united states
to make sure that
polls and and votes are are counted
fairly and that people
have their voices heard and so you hear
these reports
and the fact that they are coming out
and being talked about
talking about the united states like
that is just so concerning and it shows
just how far the united states has slid
in the past four years during donald
trump's presidency
and when trump was elected back in 2016
german chancellor angela merkel she was
the first
european ally to congratulate him with
conditions a friendship based on shared
values
she said merkel and trump ended up
sharing
very little these past four years take a
look
even before donald trump became u.s
president
it was clear the relationship wouldn't
be easy
now merkel what did she do she's
destroyed i mean she's in the process of
destroying
germany with a migration and will
once trump did become president she
congratulated him on his election
but in typical medical style she threw
in
a subtle dig
deutschland and america germany and
america are connected by values
democracy freedom respect for the law
and for the dignity of human beings
regardless of their origin skin colour
religion gender
sexual orientation or political views
einstein this photo of merkel facing
trump at a g7 meeting went viral
seen by many as a perfect illustration
of their rapport
so was their first encounter when trump
ignored mecca's suggestion to shake
hands
one of the biggest sources of
disagreement has been nato
trump has attacked germany without pause
saying it was not paying its fair share
towards the alliance
germany as you know is very delinquent
in their
payments to nato and they're paying
one percent and they're supposed to be a
two percent and the two percent is very
low it should be much more than that
when trump tweeted racist attacks on
this group of democratic u.s
congresswomen
mackel openly condemned his actions
i firmly distanced myself from the
attacks and i stand in solidarity with
these women
a strained relationship but also
opposite approaches
like on how to deal with the coronavirus
pandemic and how to wear a face mask
now with trump fighting for a second
term in office
and meckle in her last year as
chancellor it may soon be time
to kiss goodbye the question is
how soon
rachel donald trump in many ways he
looks like or has become the
anti-miracle
merkel is a scientist turned politician
trump a reality tv star
turned politician miracle's handling of
the pandemic has obviously been based in
science
trump's has been based some would say in
pr others would say
denial is this an accurate description
from where
you're sitting
i think it's a very accurate description
and
just a few years ago even when donald
trump was
elected as president people started
talking about angela merkel as the
leader of the free world
and so i think it goes to show that even
other world leaders look at donald trump
as a president that can't really be
trusted as a president who
flouts democratic norms and i think in
no relationship has that been clearer
in how he and merkel have interacted
with one another over the last four
years and the sort of disdain
that he has shown for her especially
when it comes to
german defense spending um and and
various other issues that have come up
like
for example nordstrom 2. um so i think
that if donald trump does
uh have uh is re-elected then it's
really concerning to think about where
that relationship
might be headed yeah there are
predictions that if trump wins a
re-election that
this would be the beginning of the end
of nato and that it would mean a total
withdrawal of u.s troops from
germany maybe from all of europe i mean
that's what
we're hearing on this side of the
atlantic are u.s voters aware
of what is at stake in terms of foreign
policy in this election
i think u.s voters are aware of what is
at stake and there's good news here
american voters are very supportive of
nato
and so while donald trump has used
disparaging words against the alliance
over the past four years
that really hasn't translated into a
decrease
in support for nato throughout the
united states now there is higher
support among democrats than there is
republicans
um but i think it goes to show that
americans are
you know they're they're
multilateralists at heart right they
want to see
the united states as a leader um on the
global stage and so even though donald
trump has
created problems with some of our
strongest and um
you know our historical allies since the
over the past
70 years americans themselves
still see the united states as a country
that's you know
worth being an ally to and worth being
friends with and so hopefully that's
something that continues going forward
yeah there are on tonight a lot of
people on this side of the atlantic who
hope that
your words are true political analyst
rachel rizzo joining us tonight from
washington d.c rachel good seeing you we
appreciate your insights tonight thank
you
[Music]
i have covered u.s presidential election
since 1992
and this is the first election with
violence and
unrest as a possible result the images
of businesses in washington dc and new
york city being boarded up
preparations for a hurricane have become
a bulwark against
american anger the u.s president is
responsible for much of this acute
hostility
in one of the presidential debates he
told the far-right group proud boys to
stand back
and stand by our correspondent amin
essev has been traveling across the
united states listening to people
he put this report together for us
these images are fresh in the minds of
many american voters
news of destructive protests and violent
right-wing backlash
dominated headlines for much of the
summer and early fall
[Music]
i've been traveling the country and
talking to voters and if there's one
thing americans expect
in november more than a decisive victory
for either joe biden or donald trump
it's violence that goes for biden
supporters with all these different
extremist groups and militias
i'm concerned for people's safety
they're not going to
let up peacefully as well as trump
supporters
i think if biden loses there will be
violence
there's going to be a civil war yes i
believe we're gonna hit the streets
because we're not gonna let it put up
with they're not gonna put up with this
man it's gonna be a civil war if we
don't do this
i mean they're sitting there trying to
take our guns and try to do everything
that's not gonna happen man
we're gonna stand up for what we believe
in we're gonna do the american way but
is this just
talk or is the prospect of post-election
chaos
a legitimate concern one of the reasons
people are talking about this
is because it is happening the data
does show that there has been a rise
in the number of terrorist plots
and attacks in the us in
2020 about two-thirds of them
through the first eight months were
caused by
white supremacists and far right
violent far-right extremists and about
20 by
anti-fascists anarchists and other
violent
far left but it's not just analysts who
are discussing the possibility of
disorder in november and beyond
law enforcement has already begun to
prepare i've had conversations
across state and local law enforcement
agencies
federal agencies fbi department of
justice national counterterrorism
center there is concern about the
potential for violence particularly
after the election
and and also an increase in
efforts to try to mitigate those risks
by ramping up fbi
penetration of some of the groups it's
not surprising that many americans are
uncertain of how donald trump will act
if he loses the election he's been asked
that very question
and refused to give a clear answer will
you commit to making sure that there is
a peaceful transferal of power
after the election we're gonna have to
see what happens is trump just dodging
the possibility that he could very well
lose to joe biden or is he really
implying that he would refuse to accept
the outcome of the election
when pressed another time on the
peaceful transition of power
trump said that yes he would allow biden
to take office if he won
but some analysts say that trump is
trying to gain an advantage
by casting doubts on mail-in ballots and
other common voting practices
he's basically telling the american
people that
our electoral system is unreliable
not simply unreliable that it's corrupt
that it's been rigged
and that the only way for the system to
demonstrate its legitimacy
is for him to win this incredibly
dangerous state of affairs
social media companies like twitter and
facebook have promised to clamp down on
calls for violence after the election
like the law enforcement agencies they
believe a peaceful transition of power
will require
all hands on deck
[Music]
well things look good for joe biden
heading into this election he's had a
consistent
lead in the polls pollsters however have
been wrong
like the last time in 2016 when hillary
clinton was tapped as the next
u.s president but despite her poll lead
and winning the popular vote america's
electoral college system it was a
calculus not in her favor
as votes are cast this year the latest
polls give joe biden an even
bigger national lead 8.5 percentage
points
so what lessons have pollsters learned
from that 2016
debacle and could we be looking at
another
upset well tonight we're going to try to
get some answers i'm joined by galen
druk who hosts a podcast on politics for
the analytics website
538.com heyland it's good to have you
back on the show good to see you again
on your twitter feed
i noticed you've pinned a tweet in which
people can ask you
about forecasting the election or to
forecast the election so
let me start by asking you for a
forecast what are you forecasting
well essentially our forecast at 538
takes all of the polls the national
polls the state-level polls
and creates a probabilistic forecast of
how likely it is that either candidate
will win the election so
right now on election day it was frozen
at midnight uh last night
we it shows that joe biden has a 90
chance about of winning the election
and president trump has a 10 chance of
winning a second term all right so
that's that's that's
a clear edge there for joe biden but we
all remember
the shock in 2016 the polls got it wrong
are the polls are they worthy of our
trust
this time around
there's a lot of things to think about
when we talk about trusting the polls so
first of all the national polls were not
very off in 2016.
they projected a four-point hillary
clinton win and ultimately
she received two percent more votes uh
sorry she won uh the national popular
vote basically
by two points in 2016. of course the
national popular vote doesn't really
matter in american elections
it's all about state-level elections so
that two-point difference
is about the average polling error that
we would expect in any election
now when we look at the state level
polls in wisconsin michigan and
pennsylvania which were the key states
that handed president trump his
presidency we saw that the polls were
off by
more than two points they were off by a
greater than average polling error
and what this came down to is a couple
things one
pollsters were not reaching enough
people who didn't have college degrees
when pollsters call americans
uh for some reason or another more
educated voters are likelier to answer
the pollsters
and this time around we see that
pollsters have changed the way that they
conduct their polls so that they
properly weight people without uh
college degrees
we also had more undecided voters in
2016
and they broke weight towards trump
after the comey letter to congress
uh saying that he was reopening an
investigation into hillary clinton's
emails
now in 2016 about 12
of the electorate was undecided this
time it's only four or five percent
so there's less of a chance of a
late-breaking uh
shift towards trump this time and
ultimately
you know pollsters have done a lot of
work in 2018 they were pretty spot-on
for the midterm so
i i think that we should go into tonight
with faith in pollsters
do you think though is there a risk that
um impulser's efforts do not repeat 2016
is there a risk that they have over
corrected i mean they're telling us that
joe biden has a lead but could it be
that
the real lead that he has or the edge
over trump is much larger than what
we're being told
absolutely so polling air as i mentioned
is very normal
it happens in most elections we don't
know how big it will be
and we don't know in which direction it
will go and so it's just about as likely
that the polls are underestimating biden
as it is that the polls are
underestimating
trump um you know we see that nationally
biden is about at about eight and a half
points
in pennsylvania he is closer to five
points which right now is the likeliest
tipping point state
so that's that's less of a solid lead in
the state level races
um but of course there are other places
that really biden doesn't have to win
like texas
georgia and ohio or iowa where it's only
a one-point race and if there's just a
slight pulling error there in biden's
direction
you could go from a somewhat tight race
to all of a sudden a landslide
yeah you know the historian alan listman
he has accurately predicted the outcome
of every u.s presidential election since
1984
he has his own formula known as the 13
keys to the
white house now he told me on this
program that
polls are not worth our attention
because they mean little if anything
what do you say to that i've got 30
seconds for you
i say it's the best way we have to judge
public opinion
using the scientific method the only
other way to do it is
subjectively by talking to voters here
or there in a particular town or county
the most rigorous open-minded and
thorough way to gauge public opinion in
the united states
or frankly in any country is to sample
accordingly
and that's what holsters do and yes they
are off sometimes and we should expect
that to be the case but that does not
mean we should throw out the scientific
method all together
all right cliffs that's a clear message
right there galen drew from 838.com
daley good to see you we appreciate your
insights tonight
thank you thanks a lot take care